the Joe Rogan experience first time I
went to Japan with house paint what
happened we run you know who's one of
them things were we were touring from
Toyota torch where I would go home and
literally take one set of clothes out of
a bag throw it in another bag and leave
so we got to Japan and on this
particular trip I brought my girlfriend
at that time and I think Danny did and
lethal brought his own homee or whatever
but all we brought a bunch of guests and
everybody gets through customs and as
I'm getting through customs the guy
reaches into this one jacket I have and
he pulls his hand out and there's this
little nugget of bud and he's like what
is that and I was like well can you
speak English because he said it in
Japanese so I said okay okay what is
that I was like my brain just was like
well [ __ ] man just it looks like wheat I
said it looks like we you know I just
[ __ ] owned it they went and got this
little tester put some [ __ ] in sort of
returns blue it's weed I was like it's
wait let's just [ __ ] save a little
trouble this we I mean while everybody
else had gotten through they brought in
everybody else back in right [ __ ]
gave him the [ __ ] finger like I have
like my lady everything at the time
everybody got the strip-searched
they never strip-searched me they
searched everything I had all my bags
everything right they tested one nugge
weed whatever I end up after several
hours the record label paid off whatever
they had to pay off we got into the
country and we're able to do our tour
now the point of the story is everybody
[ __ ] hating my guts the whole [ __ ]
bunch of when we get to the hotel I'm
unpacking my bag trying to figure out
how the whole [ __ ] thing happened I'm
looking at the jacket and I reach into
the pocket that was I there's nothing in
there I was like fine that's crazy I
reach into the other pocket of the
jacket I pulled out a [ __ ] ounce of
[ __ ] weed they never looked in the
other pocket of the jacket Oh [ __ ]
ounce of weed I should show you know
what you were without even knowing you
were doing it you were like sending a
small meal to get busted so that the big
ones can sneak around I must have been
rolling a joint someone at the last tour
and I had a No
left over and just thrown it in the
pocket not thinking about it on one side
cartel does that but if they would have
found that other one first I'd be in
jail in [ __ ] in Japan for a
long time ever and ever but I got it I
called the hole I called everybody that
smoked in the crew down to the room
after that and I was like yo check it
out man I really didn't mean this to
happen but I probably had more good ass
[ __ ] weed in Japan than anybody at
the time you know it's incredible
because all that was hash and [ __ ] like
that stop and think of that moment that
moment if they didn't go in that one
pocket and they went in the other pocket
first and they found that giant bag of
weed we didn't be having this
conversation no we probably would no I
don't think so
that's a lot of weed who knows though in
Japan it would have been there we took a
lot of money to get me out of that
regardless a lot instead of I think it
cost him like a thousand bucks and
they're like you know which was like ten
thousand or something yen or a hundred
salary or post put your lights on no
this was in house paint
okay this was like when the only story
like it was like Paul McCartney is
banned for life because he got caught
with some wheat that's that was like
that I don't know if it still exists but
there was a point where he was banned
for life because he got caught with weed
over there Wow well it used to be in
Nevada you get sent to jail for life if
you had weed and now it's legal there
you know there's a bunch of dudes like
looking out those barred windows bad
yeah that's just got it something's
gotta be done about that guy ain't dead
ain't working yeah that's the problem
that's the number one problem it's
number one problem with laws against
things like weed like as long as you can
buy some whiskey it's part of the number
one problem a lot of it too is a lot of
these prisoners are privatizing they
don't want to let a lot of these guys go
and a lot of these guys get money for
the amount of [ __ ] people in their
prisons I got a solution those private
prison dudes just start selling weed
right not a cleaner way to live your
life man don't be a goddamn slave owner
you know there's this whole like urban
legend that I mean it's very believable
about this letter that went around like
a bunch of people in in the in the
hip-hop music industry got not I don't
know maybe it was within the last decade
were they described like this guy
claimed to be
of the the elite a class of like
executives of the music business in
there in the mid-90s and whatnot and
there was a time when the private prison
industry came and got involved and got a
lot of these people to invest and then
kind of help direct like things like rap
music and then if you remember there
used to be like public I don't know if
you how big or you a fan of music you
were at the time X clans and Public
Enemies there was all these proactive
like you know counters to like the party
drug dealer guys or whatever you know
there was there wasn't actually another
side to it that existed and was
successful and flourished you know
amongst it you know and that disappeared
but and like there this letter that went
around was like kind of claiming this
guy was part of this thing and he left
the meeting when they these guys it was
like a whole conspiracy thing but it's
like totally believable that they were
that they could these guys would direct
a music and and a [ __ ] media in a
certain direction to encourage [ __ ]
basically a cycle of [ __ ] prison
[Applause]